[Music]
soilless
and hydroponics growing
unit five
hydroponics defined
soilless growing is nearly synonymous
with hydroponics though technically
soilless could to apply to growing with
medium like shredded bark
but for the purposes of this unit we're
treating soilus and hydroponics as the
same thing
hydroponics means growing plants without
soil using water is the medium that
holds the nutrients necessary for plant
growth
there are any number of ways to
accomplish
hydroponic growing
so the term really embraces a huge array
of possibilities including indoor and
outdoor growing trays or troughs water
only using a root support system such as
expanded clay pellets or mineral wool
and much more
for instance
a photograph of a simple hydroponic
system
hydroponics doesn't have to be
complicated as you can see from this
picture
this is very simple hydroponic growing
system a crocus bulb and a glass
bulbs such as crocus
contain sufficient nutrients to put out
leaves and flour without additional
inputs
but if nutrients were added to the water
this would qualify as a full hydroponic
system
this is a little more involved
hydroponic system
this hydroponic system
is growing plants
in screen houses outdoors this is
different from greenhouse growing the
prevailing climate has an effect the
screens
help protect the plants from insects and
other potential pests such as rabbits
and deer
while being much less expensive than
putting up a greenhouse
they can also be configured as shade
houses for crops requiring
less lighter for those crops that we
might want to shade for some reason such
as blanching
what are some of the positive aspects of
hydroponic growing
hydroponics can be done outdoors
can be done in greenhouses can be done
indoors under lights
it's suited to the production of a wide
variety of crops
perhaps one of the more important
aspects is it can be used on land that
isn't suitable for crop production
in soil such as
paved or gravel covered areas
and it can cost significantly less to
get started than the remediation of such
areas would cost
hydroponics can also be done vertically
requiring
very little ground space
hydroponic systems can be built from off
the shelf or recycled parts
weeds are generally not a problem in
most hydroponic systems
and because hydroponic systems are
self-contained pollution from runoff
isn't an issue
because there is no runoff
and even though hydroponic systems are
based on water they actually use much
less water than traditional outdoor
growing or even traditional greenhouse
growing
so what are maybe some of the negative
aspects
well they do require some mechanical
ability to set up if you get more
complicated than putting a crocus bulb
in a glass
by definition they do require the
availability of water but then so does
all growing of
plants
most systems make extensive use of
non-sustainable products such as plastic
though recycled plastic could be used
most systems require electrical power to
run the pumps
and setting up larger systems can
require a significant investment in both
time and money
and finally most fertilizers for
hydroponics are not currently organic or
sustainable in nature
so how do we grow plants
in water
well one way is to use
a root holding
medium
like these expanded clay pellets
these are
simply
pellets made from clay they don't really
maintain the nutrient levels they don't
do anything other than provide support
for the plant roots
and let the hydroponic
water
nutrient solution drain through
so that the roots have access to some
oxygen
and other root holding systems include
mineral or rockwool
lava rock pea gravel
all sorts of systems
that don't necessarily require that they
be nutrient rich
as soil growing would
here's another fairly simple hydroponic
system
this system just uses bales of straw
as the root support system
the hydroponic solution
is pumped
and drips through
down through the straw
past the root system of the plants
the solution collects on the plastic
sheets
where it can be reabsorbed by the bales
or collected at one end
and re-circulated
a system such as this might be a little
less efficient
use of water than some other systems
but it's extremely simple system to set
up
here we see a close-up of this
straw based system
and you can see running across the
top of the bales
is that black line
nutrient solution is pumped
down that black line
it then comes out of these smaller
tubes you see sticking off the side
and it can drip through the bottom of
the black line directly in the top of
the bales and then it can go through the
other lines to the side of the bales
extremely simple system and you can see
over on the left hand side how the
plastic is raised up against the edge of
the greenhouse
basically forms a trough
to allow the water to be collected and
recycled
here's a photograph showing
hydroponically grown lettuce
in a
basket using expanded clay pellets
as a root support system you can see the
roots of the lettuce plant produce
protruding from the bottom
now if you look at the photograph
carefully you can see
that the system basically consists of a
large diameter pipe
with holes the size of the pots
drilled into the pipe and the pots
simply sit in those holes the ledge or
ridge around the top of the pot
sits on top of the
pipe
keeps the pot from falling into the
into the tubing
water then containing nutrients is run
through that pipe
and
that's how the plants get their
nutrients in fact in this picture you
can see
another pipe inside the larger pipe
and that
second pipe inside the larger pipe has
holes drilled in it
tiny holes at each one of the locations
along the pipe where those pots are
placed
and they actually spray the
nutrient solution
over the pot so that the level of
nutrient solution in the pipe does not
have to be quite so high
[Music]
managing hydroponic systems
well hydroponic systems can be automated
to a great degree
the pumps for water circulation will be
set on timers
water levels nutrient levels can be
monitored electronically
because conditions are very consistent
i.e the nutrients that all the plants
get usually the amount of sunlight that
all the plants get
the
process of managing the crop
can be easier than those crops grown
in the field you get more consistent
growth
and the times for production can be more
consistent
allowing for a greater degree of
planning
and
cycling of crops
so that
maximum production can be achieved
[Music]
because of the automation
and the consistent growing conditions
that hydroponic systems have
the
systems can be run by fewer
workers than a traditional soil based
agriculture for any given crop yield
so it's a very
efficient
system
scaling and efficiency of hydroponic
systems
the systems can be designed to be
scalable that is you can start small
and then add additional capacity as
required
though with greenhouse based systems the
most efficiency is gained by utilizing
all the space in the greenhouse
at once since heating and cooling costs
remain constant
regardless of whether you're using
all the space or one tenth of space or
one half the space
however you can start with a single
greenhouse or hoop house
and add additional hoop houses as
required
and as your market grows
outdoor systems
can be scaled quite easily but are of
course at the mercy of the growing
system in northern or temperate climbs
you're not going to be producing a lot
of stuff hydroponically outdoors in
winter
[Music]
but overall
the systems are quite scalable and quite
efficient
[Music]
finally a little additional information
watch the assigned videos that's true
for all the units but
in this course in this case
the videos cover a wide range of
hydroponic setups from large factory
type greenhouses to small systems that
you can easily build from off the shelf
and recycled components
as you watch the videos pay particular
attention to the required infrastructure
from greenhouses to computer control
systems
down to the simplest systems with
buckets and hoses
[Music]
and note the relative efficiency of each
system
in terms of the manpower and other
resources required to make it run
such as electricity and heating and
cooling
and finally listen for the figures given
for crop yields
compared to traditional farming methods
you may be surprised
i want to say one more thing here about
the relative efficiency of each system
the more automated a system is the more
efficient it is
in terms of manpower however
greater degree of automation may require
more electricity
may require
more heating and cooling because
the best
most efficient automated systems are
done indoors and greenhouses
so that's a thing to watch for as you
see all these videos
and that concludes the presentation for
unit 5.
oh
[Music]